Noël 2023 sera sans doute pour lui une
année inoubliable un tour enjo a gagné
plus de 244000 € au quinté plus le 24
décembre dernier c'est le plus gros gain
de l'année en indr etloire son bulletin
a été validé dans un bar tabac de tour
sur place évidemment les clients
imaginent déjà ce qu'il ferait avec une
telle somme Faustine luno gagner 20000 €
les clients de ce barartabas de l'avenue
de la tranchée ont du mal à imaginer que
ça puisse le arriv qu'est-ce que vous
feriez si vous gagz 250000 € au Quint
comme ça du jour au lendemain
premièrement je F un petit voyage et
après je mettrai une grosse somme en
cadena c'estnaie et
puis déjà se faire plaisir sincèrement
je sais pas que ça m'arrive avant que je
puisse calculer tout ça s'occuper de la
famille déjà c'est déjà pourant c'est
bien ici dans cet établissement qu'un
client vient de rorter
44569 € au quinté plus spot après avoir
misé 2 € le 24 décembre une affaire
rentable pour ce premier grand gagnant
de l'année 2023 en indrloire une bonne
nouvelle également pour les gérants du
typ Parot qui espère que ce jackpot
attirera plus de joueurs je suis très
très très contente pour lui c'était pas
un gros joueur mais des fois de temps en
temps quand il fait ça lui prend pour le
plaisir il fait un petit spot il choisit
jamais ses numéros il fait toujours la
machine je lui fait un petit spot et
puis voilà et ça a marché là le typario
n'avait jamais validé de tickets
gagnants supérieurs à 20000 € tout jeu
et Paris confondu désormais il ne lui
reste plus qu'à afficher ce gain record
avec les
autres